I'm a biochemist I I did my thesis work
working on bacteria and then I switched
to two plants by out the biochemistry of
plants and I've worked on topics such as
how to plants make lipids and how do
plants make cellulose so the kinds of
materials that are actually used to make
biofuels my I spent my career working on
the basic mechanisms of how those things
are made by plants I got interested in
the in the field I switched to plant
specifically in the 70s when I was a
student because I was very concerned
about the sustainability of our modern
societies and that was the era in which
people like Paul Ehrlich were talking
about the population bomb and so my wife
and I my wife is also a professor at
Berkeley we decided that we needed to
start try to apply science to making at
least part of our material and food
needs more sustainable and so we've
spent our time most of our Scientific
careers working on trying to improve our
ability to manipulate plants for for
both agriculture and fuel uses and I
published about 230 papers in the field
yes the energy by science is instituted
Berkeley was founded by in response to a
solicitation by the big energy company
BP for an institute that would focus on
trying to understand how energy could be
or sorry how how modern biology could be
applied to the energy sector it was a
very kind of bold idea they were looking
around for technical innovation and to
make a long story short when I was still
a professor at Stanford I I got involved
with a person named Steve Chu at UC
Berkeley and Steve went on to become the
Secretary of Energy of the United States
and we had decided that berkeley had a
lot of capability and renewable energy
and that we should try to get this this
new center that BP was offering to fund
with five hundred million dollars so we
we wrote a proposal it was successful
and then berkeley recruited me away from
stanford to go and lead that center and
now the center has about all together
about 500 people 127 professors and
about 380 graduate students and postdocs
and we have a it's not just at Berkeley
it's at Berkeley and the University of
Illinois at urbana-champaign because
Berkeley's not a very big agricultural
school and we wanted to have a footprint
out in the agricultural region of the
country and at that Institute we're
taking a holistic view of bioenergy so
we we do economics and environmental
science and ecology mechanical
engineering Chemical Engineering
chemistry biochemistry microbiology and
law and policy and agronomy all wrapped
up into one coherent whole to try and
understand how to advance well how to
implement advanced biofuels we don't
work at all on sugar cane or corn
ethanol or biodiesel partially mostly
because those are already relatively
mature so we're really focused on
next-generation fuels
what I tried to convey in my talk is
that I I think in the in most aspects of
bioenergy there's a lot of opportunity
for innovation there's still there's
still many aspects of the process where
we don't even know what the optimal
route forward is or two what's
ultimately going to be I assume a mature
technology so I think there's lots of
interesting opportunities to get
involved with testing new ideas and try
to move them towards commercialization
my experience has been there's quite a
bit of venture capital still available
for different components of the of the
sector I myself have started three
companies two of which we're in the
bioenergy space and are two are both
thriving so I I think that's a really
exciting opportunity and it's something
that requires innovation and you know
new I new thinking and so I think that's
something that small small companies are
really well a qualified to do and then
eventually I expect the large energy
companies will ultimately come to
dominate the sort of the the very last
step of the process that is you know the
large-scale production but that they
will be large consumers of interesting
technology
I got into the field really because I
was very concerned about climate change
so when I was a professor at Stanford
actually Paul Ehrlich the father of
conservation biology it was one of my
colleagues in the Department of
Biological Sciences and Stanford also is
a very strong ecology school and my
colleagues in ecology in particular
really convinced me that the
consequences of climate change were were
serious and something that we really
should try to to bring every possible
technology to bear on so so I started
that's how I became involved with Steve
Chu and I was from some years an advisor
to the department of energy to the
director of the department of energy as
well and I got in that process I got
somewhat educated about sort of what the
challenges were and gradually turned my
own research towards towards trying to
address that challenge and I I believe
now that actually you know it is very
challenging but long term I do think
that we can introduce a basket of
technologies that will allow us to to
evolve towards a low-carbon energy
system that will still allow us to
maintain a good standard of living
around the world and so I think it's I
actually think it's really the great
problem of this generation is is how
we're going to address the energy
problem you know the energy and climate
problems shall we say and I see many
ways to do it not just in bioenergy at
Berkeley we have an integrated energy
group we call the Berkeley energy and
climate initiative that that in which
we've now got I i would estimate 1500 to
2000 scientists working across the whole
space so some of us are working on
biofuels many are working on energy
efficiency many are working on solar and
smart grid and geological sequestration
and in general I think that that's the
the big opportunity now is to
to look at everything we can possibly do
and bring as much creativity as we can
to the sector and and I think you know
but in the next 50 years we'll be able
to gradually change the society to to a
little carbon society and I think it's
very important to understand it is a you
know a 50 year or beyond kind of
initiative that we can't expect short
term you know changes and in fact I
think one of our biggest challenges is
that the popular press which is you know
it plays an important role in
understanding the problem have a very
short kind of interest they or they
assume that people have a short interest
and so they're always looking for you
know the short-term solution but
actually we're engaged in something that
requires a long-term commitment and so I
hope my one of my big hopes is that the
popular press will also get involved in
sort of keeping people's interest and
enthusiasm up as we make incremental
change towards a long-term solution
for me it would be biofuels because
right now it's the one that we do know
how to produce and it it I believe it
can be done sustainably and and it
actually can be done locally and of
course it's how we used to produce most
of our energy you know it wasn't that
long ago that that actually we got
pretty much all our energy from wood and
in fact there's a funny saying that in
the United States let's see at the turn
of a at the end of the 1900s know at the
end the 1800s so in 1900 a third of the
land in the United States roughly was
used to make transportation fuel and of
course in that day it was growing oats
for the horses that provided pretty much
all transportation and so so I actually
see the bioenergy sort of initiative as
leading us back towards a sustainable
sort of a sustainable thing and so we
knew how to do it and we're going to
relearn of course now our energy demand
has increased very strongly so we need
to be a lot better at it than we were in
you